When a Man Loves a Woman
[Applause]
America's Got Talent season five winner
Michael Graham hospitalized amid health
issues for those of you who have been
out to see Michael in the last couple of
months you may have noticed that he is
um
he was struggling with his health a lot
lacking energy and not being able to
fulfill shows that's the singer's wife
Lucy updating fans about his condition
and sharing why Michael's been M.I.A he
increasingly
think of barely walk couldn't lift his
head he couldn't respond right away to
me when I would ask him things he would
be really fuzzy but I rushed him to the
ER and they admitted him but um whatever
was going on in his body from whatever
toxins I guess they were going to his
brain he started talking gibberish
um all of a sudden like physical Tremors
were setting in Lucy says Michael's
condition got worse so doctors admitted
him into the Intensive Care Unit Michael
has been in ICU all week
for the safety of
his health they had to put him on a
ventilator
and sedate him pretty heavily so that he
wouldn't stroke out so that he wouldn't
Flatline Michael was 30 when he won
America's Got Talent in 2010 after
dedicating When a Man Loves a Woman to
Lucy who was his girlfriend at the time
[Applause]
because baby
[Music]
baby
who did you sing that for oh I sing that
for my Lucy my girl then in 2020 the
musician went on to compete on America's
Got Talent the champions
[Music]
Michael was eliminated early in the
competition but continued doing what he
loves
[Music]
way down in the valley
in the valley
and Lucy's hopeful Michael will get back
to music she says there are signs his
condition is moving in a positive
direction but the doctors were finally
able to remove the ventilator
so he's doing good
please be patient there won't be a lot
being posted from Michael or myself for
the next few
I'm going to say weeks keep an eye out
for those concerts have Michael in your
hearts and prayers and love he loves all
of you guys
stay strong thanks so much
foreign